Hello everyone. Welcome to a new episode of The
Dissenter. I'm your host, as always, Ricard Lops, and
today I'm joined by Rachel Stee. She's a self-made
porn creator, producer, director, CEO of her own production
company called Red Mill Productions. And this is again
an interview part of my humanizing sex workers series,
and today we're going to talk about Rachel's porn
career, people's common misconceptions about the porn industry and
its performers, and the topic of porn inflation, which
was recently featured on Playboy. So Rachel, welcome to
the show. It's an honor to everyone.
Thank you, Ricardo. It's an honor to be here.
I'm excited to humanize sex workers again today. Sounds
good. Yeah, it's all.
Yeah, it's one of my favorite topics. So it's
a good one, yeah, so let me start by
asking you this because you have had a kind
of unorthodox porn career, right? I mean, you've not
been one of those performers who's worked that much
for porn companies who have a contract. With a
porn company or anything like that. So, uh, but
tell us first, what really got you into pornography?
I mean, was it, um, uh, things related to
sex? Were they always something that interested you or,
uh, was it something that just you developed at
some point?
Yeah, well, it was, uh, actually by accident that
I, uh, found this industry and entered the industry.
Um, I was, uh, at the time with a
partner, uh, and he took some pictures of me.
We were having cocktails by the pool, having a
fun summer day, just having drinks and being silly,
just the two of us, and Um, I started
posing and just being funny, and he was taking
pictures, and then he developed the pictures and said,
you know, these look really good, and I follow
some, uh, older woman, sort of, uh, this was
before MILF was a thing. The word mil. Oh,
so, so, so it's even, it was even a
bit before the MILF category became a thing, was
that?
Yes, it was like in 2005 or 2006, so.
Um, HE, he said, with your permission, I'd like
to upload these pictures to a website, like a
hotwife website. They're having a contest right now, and
if you win the contest by these pictures, you
could win a cash prize. So of course I
agreed there was no nudity, uh, just sexy. Pool
pictures. Uh, HE sent them in, and I won,
uh, first place. So then it was quite a
chunk of money at that time. This was 25
years ago or something. So, it was like $600
and I was like, wow, how can I do
that again? Let's do it again. And he was
like, well, you know, you can't just do that.
So I just went on, uh, I went online
and went down a rabbit hole and started going
to these adult websites. I wasn't much of a
porn consumer at all at that time, very vanilla,
uh, just a house vanilla housewife, and, uh, just
living my life, and I owned a hair salon.
And I was just doing normal things, and, uh,
I didn't know much about sex work or porn.
Uh, AND then I stumbled into all of this,
and I started webcamming on the side because I
was getting ready to close my hair salon, and
I was really, like, wondering what am I going
to do next. I've been doing, um, the hair
salon for the last 10 or 14 years. Uh,
And I didn't have any formal education, so I
was thinking, you know, what am I going to
do for work next? So this came at the
most opportune time, and then I started, I just
fast forward, I just went right into webcamming, and
then I realized from all the customers that I
was, uh, interacting with on a daily basis, all
these fetishes and kinks, and Uh, sexual requests and
desires that I've never heard of before, I didn't
know anything about, but as a customer service person
just coming out of a hair salon business, I
was like, sure, I can do that. Yes, we
can do that, you know, and then before you
know it, I was shooting for producers in Tampa.
I was living in Tampa at the time. I
started shooting with, uh, fetish producers there, built myself
up a little bit of a reputation, a name,
Rachel Steele. Uh, THEN I quickly, entrepreneur mind that
I have, said, I can do this myself. I
don't want to be a model. I wanna be
the owner. I wanna be the creator, the one
that's, uh, that owns the content, and then that's
how it all, that's how my Red Mill Productions
began.
Uh, SO in terms of your porn career, you
never really worked much for other people, or, or
did you?
Correct, um, I worked for many amateur, um, sites,
the fetish, uh, side of porn, but mainstream, I,
I didn't dabble in at all. I, I, I
didn't care for the style. Um, I'm more of
an erotic, sensual, seductress kind of performer. I like
things to slowly unfold, really bring up the, the,
get things simmering, and then a boil, and then,
you know, the finale. I don't want to just
open the door and go, oh, you're the plumber.
Come and fix my pipes. You know what I
mean? I want it to, to have a storyline.
So I, mainstream porn was just very quick and
very raw and gonzo, and it wasn't my style.
I didn't feel comfortable with that kind of, um,
content, so I just decided to stay away from
mainstream and just really focus on producing my own
content, which was also unheard of 20 years ago.
PEOPLE didn't, we, there was no social media, no
Instagram, nothing. So, this mindset that I had was,
was what's happening today with, uh, original content creators.
So, I, I really did get, get a good
jump, uh, ahead of the game by, by thinking
that way of, I want to do this on
my own. I want to be the boss. I
want to own the, the content and everything about
it, and have my name stamped on it. Not
modeling for other companies where they're going to then
market that product and be able to sell it
over and over and over, and I get paid
one time. So it's just a pretty easy math
equation.
Yeah, you've definitely had a very unique kind of
porn career. I mean, uh, did, did you grow
up quickly on the internet? I mean, how fast
did it happen? And do you think that at
least part of it, part of your success has
been due to the fact that you sort of
attend to those more kind of fetish, kink, kind
of niche things in porn?
Yeah, um, I started really producing in about 2006,
and, um, in about 2007 or 2008, uh, a
fan reached out to me and asked me if
I would consider doing, um, a custom video where
it was mother-son. And I had never thought about
this before. I was just doing MILF, older woman,
younger man. Scenarios, um, and I decided, I, I,
you know, spoke to my partner about it, and
he was like, no, don't do that, you can't
do that. Don't do that. That's, oh, I'm like,
this is fantasy. He's not my son. He's just
a guy that I'm hiring. Come on, this is
like the movies, like you watch movies, you know,
Char, um. Those celebrities that play murderers aren't really
murderers in their real life, so this is fantasy
roleplay. So I agreed to do it. I did
that film, and it went crazy. It went viral
and it shot me up to Number 1 on
the charts, uh, on a clip site called Clips
for Sale. And then my studio was at #1,
and I stayed at number 1 for almost 10
years after that. So, it really, uh, shot me
up to the top, and then I was known
as the taboo MILF. And now, today, everything is
step according to the, the law. We have to
follow the guidelines, and we have to use the
word stepmother now. We can't do mom, son. So,
um, you know. The, the, the whole outlook has
changed, but that's what really shot me up to
the top and kept me there, and made me
kind of a trailblazer for, for this whole genre.
Yeah, it's interesting because I've interviewed people who are
really, I mean, some of them are legends of
the industry, people like Nina Hartley, Brittany Andrews, Rachel
Devine, and it's interesting because some of them at
least were already shooting in the 80s, 90s, so
they went through. That period in the porn industry
where you still had VHS and then DVD, but
when you went through the industry, actually it was
already around that period of time where porn on
the internet was already or starting to bloom,
right? Yes, mhm.
Yeah, so, so you basically also rode that wave
of porn on the internet, and then, I mean,
how do you look back in terms of how
your porn career on the internet has looked over
time because of course there were those early days
in the 2000s, but then I mean even the
different porn companies started moving. More and more into
the internet and they no longer even, I mean,
VHS, no, no one sells VHS nowadays, but even
DVDs are more, more and more rare nowadays. But
with the introduction of even platforms like OnlyFans and
other websites like that, how have you seen the
industry on the internet changing over time?
Yeah, well, there's definitely more opportunity, um, as a
producer, a CEO of a production company, and a
performer, there's definitely more opportunity, um, because there's so
many platforms where you can sell your product, um,
so that's, you know, that's a positive thing, um.
And, but at the same time, there's a lot
of competition, or saturation, more so than competition, because
we all kind of can mirror each other and
promote each other, uh, and, but, um, you know,
there's a lot of saturation, so it, it's And
OnlyFans is, is a wonderful opportunity as well. However,
it's can be exhausting. It can take up your
full day. You could literally be hunched over a
phone chatting all day long, just on OnlyFans. What
about all the other Administrative work that needs to
be done. So there's a lot on creators right
now because there's so much. You've got Instagram, you've
got all the social media channels. There's so much
dumped on new creators or creators that are just
trying to keep their head above water. Uh, AND
not disappear online. So the pressure, uh, the algorithms
of the pressure of the, of all of that
getting shut down on social media, uh, worrying about
all of those sorts of things happening can affect
your income. Uh, WE have banking issues now. I
don't know if you heard about Cherie Deville. Uh,
Bank of America just shut her accounts and they're
holding her money. Uh, IT'S insane like what's happening.
So there's a lot of good, but then there's
a lot, uh, on the other side that we're
dealing with as well. So I'm just really grateful
that I started 20 years ago. I skyrocketed. I
continued to produce for about 15 years, nonstop every
single day, 5 days a week, 3 shoots a
day for 15 years. So I have the huge
library, 4 or 5000 videos are all on, all
on my website, and I'm continuing shooting all the
time. LA, Las Vegas, new talent, mainstream talent. Um,
SO I'm lucky where I've got this library, and
I'm able to, I have content. I don't have
to be a slave to the machine, so to
speak.
Yeah, right, I mean, maybe later if we have
time we might get into some of those issues
in terms of how in the US particularly, but
maybe also other countries, very unfortunately sex workers have
been targeted for the past few years on the
internet and also w he re uh, but I
would like to ask you, what would you say
are the main differences or what do you find
to be the main differences between being a content
creator slash performer, a producer, and a director because
you have fulfilled all those roles.
Yeah. Well, currently, I am all of those roles
on set. So, um, I've, I've really only stepped
out maybe a handful of times and just directed
behind the camera with other people. Um, I'm slowly
introducing more of those scenes because eventually, um, You
know, 5, 10 years from now, I might not
want to be in front of the camera, um,
but I'll still be producing Red Mill Productions as
an empire. It's not gonna just stop. Uh, IT'S
gonna continue. I'll have a team in place that'll
produce and direct and film and do everything. So,
it'll always be producing porn, um. But, you know,
right now it it's, it's tricky to do all
of that when you're in front of the camera
as well, but that's what I've been doing for
so many, for two decades. So I've, I've kind
of, you know, blended it all together into one,
little thing that I, I'm, I'm used to doing
this, uh, this way, so I don't really separate
being a performer, uh, from a director cause I'm
As soon as people walk in the room, I'm
like, OK, this is what's gonna go down. You
are my stepson, you are the next door neighbor,
and, you know, so I'm telling the story, writing
the story, directing it, producing it, and acting in
it.
I mean, it's interesting that you fulfill all those
roles. Uh, WHAT perspective uh does that give you
in terms of pornography? Do you look at it
as a form of art?
Mhm. Yes, I do very much so. Um, I
don't even like to use the word, I'm a
porn star, or I film pornography. I'm a film
producer, and I'm an actress, and that's how I
look at it, because I have to play, uh,
I have the opportunity to play so many different
roles, um, whether they are demure and innocent, or
Pervy and aggressive, or, you know, I've just so
many different roles. I, I like to play. I
do Wonder Woman. I do fetish. I'm a dominatrix,
so I go deep on psychology and, uh, what
people's kinks and fetishes are. I have private sessions
with individuals, um, that gets, it can get really
intense psychologically. Um. So it's absolutely so much more.
So, one woman said to me the other day,
she said, well, You're lucky because you shoot porn
and you like having sex, and she just left
it at that. And I was like, wow, do
you think that because I shoot porn is the
way you put it, it's just because I like
to have sex, that's why I shoot porn, like,
It's, you know, that's just not the case. Of
course, I love sex and enjoy sex, but I'm
also producing film. This is storylines, taboo fantasies, fantasy
roleplay situations. So we're acting just like on TV
in the movies. All these movies we watch are
made up storylines, uh, with people acting. Um, IT'S
the same thing in Shooting, uh, porn, it's, it's
film production from, from my, my, my, uh, production
company is that way anyway. There's a beginning, a
middle, and an end. There's characters, there's role, role
playing, there's different, uh, costuming, you know, changes, um.
So, it's definitely an art. You're always thinking about
camera angles and lighting, uh, people's, um, how they're
acting, or if they're supposed to be happy and
excited, are they really portraying that? So you do
several takes over and over. Let's try that again
this time with a little more excitement. So, If,
if someone were to just come with me for
a week or so and follow me from shoot
to shoot to shoot, they'd see all, all that
goes into it. It's just so much more than
popping on a push-up bra and having sex with
some hot young guy. It's just way beyond that.
Yeah, how much prep goes into it, uh, actually?
I mean, uh, I'm not even talking about, uh,
during the shooting itself, but before the shooting, how
much prep time does it take?
Yeah, before the shooting, uh, so for me, I
live in San Diego and I shoot in LA.
So I'll drive to LA the day before. I
will rent a place like an Airbnb or someplace,
um. So, there's a whole day of getting there,
unloading all my stuff, the equipment, the lights, all
my clothing, hang everything up, put it all in
the closet, get it all ready, all the shoes
lined up. Then I have a makeup artist who
comes the next morning, a good 1.5 to 2
hours prior. Um, I have a cameraman, a videographer
who shows up about 30 minutes prior, and then
he sets up all the lighting and asks, where
are we starting, what Room we're gonna be in,
we go over the script, then the male model
or the female model will show up, and then
we all sit down and do paperwork where we
check IDs, we check each other's, um, STD testing,
make sure everyone's cleared, uh, for, uh, sex, sexual
testing. Um, THEN we go over the script and
the storyline, make sure that everyone understands what their
roles are and what things will be said. Um,
AND then we talk about, uh, consent. We discuss
in the group, what, what, you know, where do
you wanna be touched, how do you wanna be
touched? Where do you not wanna be touched? What
do you not allow? Where, what are your boundaries?
Um, IS everyone comfortable with the scenario and the
scene and the sex that's gonna happen? AND And
then we start shooting. So, you know, it's at
least a 4 to 6 hour day. Just for
1 1520 minute scene that you see when it's
completely fully edited, that took a whole day to
produce and thousands of dollars.
Yeah, it's a full work day, right,
actually, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah. So I mean, I wanted to ask you
about your thoughts on the MILF category because of
course you're very much associated with that and it's
interesting because when, for example, I interviewed Nina Hartley
the first time. I asked her if she thought
that, for example, having categories in porn like male
and interracial, if it would help, for example, with
diversity with, in the case, I mean, having female,
older females in the industry, having, having black people
in the industry, and so on. Uh, AND she
actually told me, and I mean, she's extremely experienced.
She's, uh, she's have a, uh, uh, she's had
a 40 plus year career by now, so she's
been at it since 1984 or something like that.
Uh, AND, uh, she told me actually that she
thinks that it's sort of a double-edged sword sword
in the sense that, yeah, OK, so maybe it's
easier now than it was before. For for the
industry to accept older women into it and more
diverse people, I mean more diverse kind of bodies
and races and all of that, but at, uh,
but at the same time she thinks that there's
also the issue of fetishization in the sense that,
yeah, OK, so the porn industry basically uses. Older
women, black people, and other people like that as
a fetish, and they're not really doing that to
really promote diversity and inclusion and all of that,
but just because they are, I mean, using those
social categories as fetishes. I mean, what do you,
what is your take on that?
Yeah, I, I would tend to agree with Nina,
and I've worked with Nina before. Um, I know
her well, and she's, um, a legend in the
industry, absolutely, and a very intelligent woman, uh, and
I love her, her mindset and her, her outlook.
Um, AND I agree, um, I've seen a lot.
You know, and it's funny that you bring this
up cause I really never thought about this until
you just brought it up and put it into
this, um, you know, this perspective, but I agree
with that. I, I, I always say in my
personal private life, uh, I don't want to be
put in a box with a bunch of other
people, you know, I just don't want to be
stamped, labeled, and put in a box, because we're
all human beings, and each one of us has
our very own fingerprints. So how can you say
that we're all MILFs, just because we're a certain
age, or, um, you know, just because you have
big boobs, you're just this big tittied MILF. You
know, there's so much more to these individuals, and
also for black, uh, black. Men in the industry,
the BBC, I don't really care the way that
they market and advertise that either, because I feel
like they're just literally focusing on the guy's dick
and nothing else about this man. He's a man.
He's got a mind. He's got a brain. He's
an actor, producer, director, just like me, you know,
there's so much to these individuals, and unfortunately they
just get marketed in this manner, and I don't
care for it myself personally. I really don't care
for it. Um, AND that's why, you know, I'm,
I'm not a mainstream producer or actor. Um, JUST
to, just to defend mainstream a bit though, I
have shot in multiple mainstream, uh, for mainstream companies,
and they've been wonderful to me, and they're wonderful,
uh. And, you know, they help my brand. I
get a lot of eyes on my brand when
I do show up on a mainstream shoot. So,
I don't wanna put it, put them all in
the mud. But, um, yeah, I, I really do
wish that things would get a little bit kinder
and a little more humanized, to be honest. A
little more real. But with AI company now, with
the digital twins, and even more, you know, I,
I'm really curious to see what our world is
gonna look like in the next 3 to 5
years.
No, I, I mean, I, I'm really not a
fan of AI. I'm, I really like, uh, real
people doing real things, but, well, let's see, let's
see what happens. But I mean, getting, getting into
some of the misconceptions that people have about the
industry and the performers, particularly. Um, I mean, I,
I'm going to ask you about your broader views
about it, but, uh, what do you make of
when people accuse, for example, the industry itself or
even the performers specifically of promoting, uh, I don't
know, nonconsensual sex, or promoting sexual assault, of promoting
sexual violence. I mean, for It's always been a
bit silly, not just because those kinds of claims
are not supported by the science, and I've talked
on the show with neuroscientists and psychologists about it,
but it's not just that, but it's also, I
mean, the way I think people should approach pornography
is as a form of entertainment, as a form
of art. I mean, it's those kinds of. Accusations,
it's the same thing that we've heard people, for
example, accusing violent video games of promoting violence. I
mean, when you play Grand Theft Auto, you don't,
after the fact, just suddenly go out on the
street with an AR-15 and start shooting at people
and robbing cars and all of that. I mean,
it's, it should be treated as entertainment.
Absolutely. Yes, and, and that's one thing that, um,
that I say a lot is porn is not
a source of sexual education. Um, IT'S not a
place where you can learn how to be intimate
with your partner. Uh, IT'S not a place where
you can learn much about real sex, to be
honest, because it is choreographed, um, art. It's a
form of live art, um. And we, you know,
we're camera ready. We are performing because there's a
camera there, so we're doing different movements and positions
that normally you wouldn't be doing in your private
life, in your intimate life. Um, AND Uh, I
do the nonconsensual, uh, or what is it called?
Consensual non-consent. I have, uh, hundreds, uh, if not
1000, 1200, something like that, videos, damsel in distress.
I was doing this back in the day, and
it was, you know, grab and attack, and tie,
gag, and then fuck, you know, uh. Damsel in
distress video. I've been doing that for 15 years,
and now I can't sell it on most platforms,
cannot sell it. And it's me in the video
with my current, my partner at the time, who
was my husband, and we're following the 2257 guy.
Guidelines, federal guidelines were filming me before and after.
Were you harmed or injured? Did you do anything
against your will today? Were you under the influence
of drugs or alcohol? What's today's date? What is
your name? How old are you? You know what
I mean? Like we follow everything. This is fantasy
roleplay film production. And again, you can watch Game
of Thrones. There's violence, there's sex, there's incest. It's
OK. It's a Hollywood production. Sell it. But, uh,
I can't sell a damsel in distress video that
I made with uh my husband. So, you know,
be careful, follow the, follow the rules, follow the
guidelines, make sure everyone is consenting, have proof of
consent, um, and I don't know why we shouldn't
be able to produce. Uh, WE are very discriminated
against, um, as, uh, filmmakers because we are filmmakers.
We have full productions. Some of the mainstream productions
are $200,000 to $30,000 a day that their, uh,
you know, cost is, and we can't say this,
we can't do that. We can't have a glass,
a wine glass in our hands. ANY longer with
water in it. We can't portray that we're having
a cocktail. We can't sleep on, on screen anymore.
I can't lay down with my eyes closed. Or
if I have to do my eyes closed, nobody
can even touch me to wake me up. That's
considered non-consent. It's unbelievable, you know, what we're being
restricted on now. So, Yeah, things, I hope things
can change in a more positive light, and, you
know, these federal laws and all these guidelines can
be understood that this is production and it's fantasy
film.
Yeah, so as I was telling you just before
we started recording, I, I very much identify as
a feminist, as a male feminist, but I'm a
sex positive feminist, not that kind of sex negative
feminist, particularly the Radical feminists who position themselves against
the sex work, pornography, and I mean, many different
kinds of sexual expression. I mean, one of the
arguments that very commonly I hear from them and
we hear from them is that, I mean, people,
particularly the female performers. ARE exploited that they are
basically victims that no woman out there out of
her own free will chooses to become a porn
performer or a sex worker of any Other kind
that they're, they're always coerced into it. I mean,
don't you think that that's perhaps a bit, um,
that's perhaps being patronizing to females who are sex
workers?
Oh, absolutely, and, uh, everything that you just stated
is absolutely 100% incorrect and wrong. Uh, IT'S mis
misinformation. It's perspectives coming from places of, uh, you
know, beliefs. Systems and cultural systems in place that
are just against, um, you know, this whole industry
as a whole, um, but the industry as a
whole and sex work as a whole is very
healing. It's a very safe place. It's a very
good place to be. Um, AS a dominatrix, I've
been able to see people's Uh, when they tell
me they're kinks, they actually have so much shame
around their kinks because of the way they were
brought up and raised, whether it be in a
religious home, telling them that they were sinners and,
uh, shameful, and, uh, sick, um, disturbed. Like you
wouldn't believe the stories that I've heard, the shame
built around. Uh, JUST one sexual thought, you know.
So, this is, this can be a very healing,
uh, space for people, for sex workers and for
the customers, um, the clients, the fans, the followers.
It's very liberating. It provides jobs and work for
people that, you know, like I said before, I
was in the salon industry, and then that had
to end pretty quickly because the neighborhood got really
dangerous, and I literally had to close my business,
and I was like, what am I going to
do? I don't have the money to open another
hair salon. Um. And I don't have any, like,
I, I, I don't have any skills. I would
just have to get a job wherever I could
apply for a job and work in a bakery,
in a retail store, you know, in a restaurant
serving, and that's my future. So, now I'm a
CEO of my own company, um, million dollar company,
and still growing. I'm having a marketing thing coming
soon. I have a production company. I did this
all as a A young single female, uh, with,
with just barely a high school diploma. So, this
whole being exploited, I've chosen not to, uh, to
work with whoever I want to work with. So,
I'm not exploited. Um, I'm, I'm doing what I
want to do with who I want to work
with. I'm also on a WhatsApp messaging group with
several 100 different porn stars, if not more than
several 100 there's a lot. And These women are
all chatting away about how their life is. They're
all independent workers with their own businesses. They're making
their own money. They own their own homes, their
cars. They're paying their bills. They're living their lives.
They're supporting their children. They are doing what they
want. To do when they wanna do it with
who they wanna do it, um, you know, since
OnlyFans started, people are working from home more. Um,
SO this is a very empowering industry, um, and
it's a business just like every other business too,
so there's so many opportunities. And there's so many
good people that are in this industry as well,
and good companies and really legitimate business-minded entrepreneurs and
a big support system within the industry of sex
work in a whole, not just film, but sex
workers or escorts, you know, people, all, all, all
walks of life. So I support it 100%, and
I think that it gives people a lot of
opportunity.
Don't you think that when people like these sex
negative feminists that uh curiously enough many times because
they are against sex work even though feminism supposedly
is progressive, end up aligning themselves with conservative people
to try to bring down sex work, to try
to ban it on the internet, ban it on
social media. To try to impose sin taxes on
social workers, to try to criminalize sex workers, sex
work and all of that, don't you think that
they actually might end up putting sex workers at
risk, at financial risk, uh, at the risk of
having to work in less safe environments and all
of that.
Absolutely, yes. Um, Yes, to, to all of that.
It, it does put everyone at risk, um, you
know. Making it criminal, illegal, um, it, it's the
oldest profession in the world, so it's not gonna
go away. Also, this industry makes more money than
Google, NFL, and Apple combined, you know, something like
that. It literally does, uh, and so all these
individuals who criticize it are probably some of your
biggest fans watching it, uh, because they're lying if
they say they don't. This is normal human behavior,
and we need to drop the whole facade and
stop all the shame around nudity and. Sex and
people's kinks and fetishes and desires. Instead learn about
them. The power is knowledge, you know, the more
knowledge is power, the more you know, uh, the
more you understand and the easier things can be
and people can live peacefully and, and be accepted
for who they are and how they feel and
creators can create fantasy roleplay things for people to.
View as entertaining for their pleasure, for their entertainment,
uh, and the more that we negate this, this
industry and the people in the industry, uh, the
more dangerous it does become for them. Um, AND
I think it's great that you're doing this podcast
and using these words, this language like humanizing sex
workers because we, we. We are human and we
do live our lives every day. We wake up
with messy hair and pajamas on backwards and have
to figure out what we're gonna cook for breakfast,
you know, and walk the dog if he didn't
already pee on the floor. And, you know, we're,
we're just everyday people, and we're doing things that
those negative, those negative Nancy's out there. ARE watching.
So it's really time to just stop. It's just
so silly, you know, it's like we're dealing with
a bunch of toddlers. Um, AND I hope that
as time goes on, we become a more progressive,
open-minded society. Um, I don't see a lot of
signs of that happening, but, you know, I, I
do have hope, but Yeah, making it, criminalizing it
and, and stuff like that does make it very
unsafe. Um, YOU know, if you get assaulted, you
can't go to the police. If you, you know,
get debanked, you can't open a bank account. How
are you going to pay for your bills? How
are you going to survive? So there's definitely things
that are happening that we're, we, um, as a
whole, we're all, uh, trying to, to become a
little more like activists in this industry when this
banking thing happened to, uh, performer. Called Cherie deville,
uh, we literally all went online and started reposting,
reposting, and tagging the bank to let them know
we're not gonna just sit around and be quiet
and let you do this to us because you
don't like what we do. We're paying taxes. We've
got a legitimate business. We've got a license. We've
got an LLC. We're incorporated. What more do you
want, you know, and then you just shut the
bank down. Nope, you can't, you can't bank here.
We don't like what you do.
Yeah, I mean, what have you seen to be
some of the biggest threats to sex workers online,
particularly over the past few years? I mean, apart
from things like their banks. Sending them in some
way or another and them not being able to
access their money or some of their money, I
mean, things that occur on how in terms of
how sex workers are targeted on social media, for
example, and the internet more generally and some. Measures,
political measures that people have been trying to implement
to try to actually ban porn and other kinds
of sexual expression from the internet. I mean, what
do you think are the biggest or have been
the biggest threats recently?
Well, really, um, Pretty much everything that you listed
is, uh, a threat, and I see a lot
of very negative, uh, comments on social media. Um,
uh, FORTUNATELY, I haven't received a lot of negativity
in my whole career. It's been really good, but
I've seen like others, uh, receiving a lot of
negativity, really nasty comments, hateful. Um, COMMENTS that to
me are threatening, um, things like, you're a dirty
whore, you're diseased, and, you know, just these, these
horrible comments coming, um, and that kind of hate.
IS eye-opening, and it, it feels very threatening and
violent to me, verbal violence. Um, SO I guess
the negativity that is around and the, the myth
and the misunderstandings about what we do and who
we are as people, so that really needs to
change to make it more of a safe space.
Do you think that there's still lots of social
stigma attached to being a sex worker, even nowadays?
I do. And even just for myself, um, I,
I have this conversation with my partner a lot
because I struggle, psychologically, I struggle and I feel
really bad, and I feel sad, and I feel
alone sometimes. I feel, uh, I actually have a
part of my brain that's telling me and whispering
that I'm doing something wrong, bad, shameful. Um, AND
the reason I feel these feelings is because when
I go out into the real world, I just
moved to San Diego a couple of years ago,
I moved to San Diego, but I just purchased
a home in San Diego, and I have neighbors,
and some of my neighbors have teenage kids, and
I literally don't tell them what I do for
a living, because I don't know that they would
be safe, feel safe with that, you know, that
they would judge me. As some kind of person
that's not safe, and, oh no, a porn star
lives right there. Oh my God. You know, like
I, I have no idea how these people are
gonna think. I haven't told any of my neighbors
what I do for a living. So, and when
we meet new people, I don't just volunteer what
I do because I don't know how they're gonna
be, how they're gonna feel, react. Um, WE did
meet a couple, uh, just a month ago or
so in the neighborhood. And they seemed really cool.
So, I told them right away who I am
and what I do, and we haven't seen them
since. So, it's really hard to make friends that
are genuine, that accept you for who you are
and what you do as a, you know, as
a, you know, as a, a career. And these
people are 30s, 40s, and 50s. So, you know,
it's like, if they can't accept what I'm doing,
well, you know, So it's really a, a real
thing, and it's really, um, we have uh friends
that are a queer couple, and they don't want
to hear about my work either. Um, IF I
start talking about, they'll say, how was your weekend?
I went to LA to work, and I'll say,
oh, it was great. I shot with this new
male talent, and he was really cute, and we,
we had a great scene, and they're just like,
oh, that's good. And they just shut down. They
don't want to hear, and I'm not gonna go
into detail, you know, and make it real nasty,
but I can't even talk about my day. I
can't talk about my work. I can't share the,
the growth that my business has had, um, you
know, it, it's, it's sad, and it's like, these
people should be people I should be able to
talk to. Just have a conversation like I'm having
with you right now. Um, BUT boy, when you
say that you're a sex worker or you're a
porn producer, people's minds, spaces, body language change, and
it's rare to find people that are like, oh,
that's so cool. Tell me more. It's just not
happening, so that kind of tells you what's going
on out in the in the world.
No, I get really bothered by that, and that's
one of the reasons why I've been doing this
series on my podcast and YouTube channel. I mean,
because many times it's just the things that people
think about sex workers, it's just based on assumptions,
stereotypes, prejudice. I mean, sometimes I even get angry
and ask people, have you ever talked To a
sex worker, have you ever met a sex worker?
I mean, they're just regular, normal, normal people like
you and I. There are extremely intelligent, entrepreneurial, and
other kinds of positive traits that you can associate
in anyone. You can also, you can also find
sex workers that are all of that and even
more. I mean, I've had some of my, my
favorite conversations. On the show I've been with sex
workers with Nina Hartley, Alice Little, and others. I
mean, it's just fascinating also because you guys also
have a particular perspective on sex, sexual expression, and
all of that, that norm is like me and
other people don't get. So I just find it
really fascinating and then associated, associating with other aspects
of life. And I mean sometimes it really Hurts
me. Earlier I talked about feminism. I'm also a
socialist and it really hurts me because it's very,
very common for me to hear people who are
socialists, communists, and so on also being positioning themselves
against sex work because they're always saying that, oh,
it's debasing, it's objectifying, it's not a dignifying job,
it's not a dignifying occupation. And I don't want
the state to have anything to do with that.
And then they start to talking about how they
don't want the state to get to legalize or
decriminalize sex work because they don't even want to
touch on money coming from taxes, from taxes from
sex work. And I mean for me it's just
ridiculous. It's just people not really ever talking to
sex workers.
Yeah, and I would like to ask some, someone
who has that stance. I would love to really
have them give an honest answer. Um, WHAT sex
do you have? Like, what is your sexual life?
They would never answer, of course, but I would
love to know because we're all human beings at
the end of the day. Uh, HOPEFULLY, we all
have desire and libido, and, you know, want to
have pleasure in our lives in, in one form
of intimacy or another that might involve sexual, you
know, whatever. I know some people are asexual and
And, you know, some people might have trauma. I'm
not saying everyone should have sex and like it
and love it, you know, but I would love
to ask this person that is so stance against
it, like, what kind of sex do you have?
If you're saying it's objectifying, then how do you
feel when you see a woman's breasts? If you're
sexually turned on, you are objectifying that woman's breasts.
You should not look at breasts, you know, like,
and then if you don't look at the breasts
and keep yourself covered up, and you live like
that for five years, you are going to fetishize
those breasts because you can't have, you can't see
it. It's like telling someone there's cooked fresh baked
cookies over there, but do not touch or eat
them. You know, you can smell them, but you
can't eat them or touch them. It's just, it's
just not real, you know, and, and it's just,
um, unfortunately, this has been going on since the
beginning of time, you know, the judgment, the shame,
and then you build religious. Beliefs around that, and
then you have this little culture, and now everyone,
you all should be in the same little boxes
and believe the same things. And when someone steps
out, well, that's when you point your finger and
judge and shame and get rid of that, and
get rid of this. But, you know, I, I
just don't see that it's, uh, realistic.
Yeah, but do you think that pornography is for
everyone, I mean, not everyone in the sense necessarily
that anyone should watch it, but more in the
sense of whether you think that anyone could be
a good porn performer or could do well working
in pornography.
Yeah, I think that that's a very personal individualized,
um, question for the, for each individual to ask
themselves, and to be very honest. Um, WHEN I
first fell into the industry, I, I was uh
very apprehensive and intimidated by mainstream. Um, BECAUSE whenever
I did turn on vanilla mainstream porn, I personally
was not drawn, attracted, turned on by it at
all. And 20 years ago, there wasn't a whole
lot of diversity in porn. So, it was kind
of, that's all there really was. Hot blonde women
with big, uh, you know, fake implants getting railed
by men with penises down to their kneecaps. And
I was like, Like, oh, I, uh, well, first
of all, I don't look like her, and I've
never seen a man like that. And I don't
think I could have sex like that. And so,
I just couldn't relate to it. Um, AND today,
we've got so much more happening, and so more,
there's some really great production companies out there doing
more realistic storylines, uh, where people can really relate
to the characters and even look and think like,
oh, I kind of look like her, or I
look like that man. Um, AND so I think
that we, we have more opportunity today to, to
be creators. So anyone out there that's even thinking
about doing this, I would say, if you have
an interest in this and you think that this
is something you might wanna explore, do it on
your own. TERMS, do it all, your own ideas,
be you. Always stay true and be you. Um,
DON'T, you can watch other things to get ideas,
but don't try to recreate or be like this
or be like that, or do anything that doesn't
feel right to you. Um, AND if it feels
right to you and you're enjoying and you're having
a good time, then you should go for it
because it, it's a very liberating experience. It's really
helped resolve a lot of traumas in my life,
my personal life that I've had. I've been in
therapy for many years, um, and shooting like this
and, um, experiencing and, uh, Living this lifestyle that
I've been living the last two decades has really,
uh, helped to heal me psychologically, spiritually, sexually. Um,
SO, it's been, um, an, an amazing journey and
experience for me, and I would highly recommend it,
but it, it, it's only for people that want
it. You wouldn't do this just because you think
you can make some money, you know, I, I
wouldn't recommend that.
Do you have a different outlook on sex now
than you had 20 years ago?
Definitely, definitely, yeah, um. And it's been an interesting
journey for me, and it's taken a long, slow
time for me too, because I was very vanilla
when I first entered in. So, my way of
thinking back then was very different from the way
I'm thinking right now today, um, with all the
years that have gone by, and all the different
people that I've worked with, and Um, entering into
the dominatrix and the BDSM realm, um, has really
opened my eyes, and I've realized a lot of,
uh, psychology, um, archeeotypes, and trauma-based. Oh, setbacks, holdbacks,
blockages, um, those things have been released and, and
opened for me, and now I'm actually having the
best sex of my life, um, you know, now,
because my mind is more open. Um, I feel
safe. I know that I'm loved and I'm safe,
and I'm choosing everything that I wanna do and
who I wanna work with, and what we're going
to do, what the storyline will be, and it's
becoming, like, a lot of fun instead of work.
Yeah, I mean, I actually think that many of
the people who position themselves against sex work must
have some form of unhealthy relationship with sex themselves.
I mean, because I don't think you should think
it's normal for you to find sex or certain
kinds of sexual expression disgusting. Right.
Um, YES, um. I think that having a healthy
mindset is first and foremost, you know, the most
important part of being able to, uh, explore sex
and sexuality, feeling safe, surrounding yourself with people that
are of the same mindset, where there's no shame,
um, there's support, encouragement, um, it, it can be
an amazing journey when you find your community. Um,
THE sky is the limit.
Yeah, so I have just one last topic I
wanted to ask you about because you actually were
interviewed for a piece that featured on Playboy about
rising production costs in the porn. Industry. So when
since you are a business owner and a porn
producer and director, uh, tell us about that. I
mean, in what ways have, uh, has inflation in
recent times impacted the production of porn?
Yeah, well, um, I've been on set with mainstream,
and I was literally counting all the girls that
are there, and I know what their rates are,
and then there's a couple of guys, I know
what their rates are, then they've got two videographers,
a still photographer, a guy that's putting the lights,
and a guy that's running and getting all the
food, the director. And I'm adding it all up
and I'm like, oh my gosh, I, I just
counted 30,000 already, and this is for a 4
hour day. So for 1 20 minute, maybe 30
minute, uh, Clip, you know, so, as a small
producer, um, I, I don't spend that kind of
money on one, production, but it's at least $5000
or $6000 for each one that I produce, um,
and your time and travel, um. It's getting trickier
for locations because a lot of Airbnbs don't allow,
um, so, you know, you don't, and I don't
want to shoot in hotel rooms because I like,
I'm a very storylined, uh, producer. I want a
house. I want a living room, a kitchen, a
bedroom. I want to set the scene and, you
know, make people feel like it's a lot more
than just hotel door, open the door, there's a
bed, and that. That's it, you know, um, so
it's getting tricky with locations on where we can
film, where we're allowed to film, um, people's rates
are going up, which is, that's fair, but it's
getting harder to, um, hire folks too, because everyone's
doing OnlyFans. Um, AND my, my red flag for
Only. Fans is to tell every creator out there
is to not put all of your eggs in
that one basket and just focus on OnlyFans only,
that's it, because OnlyFans could collapse tomorrow, you know,
political climate, someone could buy it from somebody else
and just say, now we're not gonna allow any
more adult stuff on here. It's only for athletes
and celebrities, you know, you just don't know what's
gonna happen next, so. You know, it's definitely getting
a little bit uh more uh more expensive and
a little bit trickier, uh, difficult for for producers,
for sure.
Uh, YEAH, what do you think are perhaps some
of the biggest challenges, uh, I mean, currently and
in the near future?
The biggest challenge is, hm. Well, It's, for me,
it's definitely where we have a lot of really
great talent, but it's definitely the male talent is
becoming, uh, can become a little bit of a
challenge. Uh, IT'S, it's a lot harder for men
in the industry than it is for women to
perform. And that, that's becoming, it's always been an
issue, um, but it, you know, the more. The
more quantity that they put out, the more we
use the same guys over and over, and these
guys, their bodies, they can only do so much.
So there's a lot going on behind the scenes
with, um, men in the industry having to inject,
uh, their penises with drugs that will keep them
hard or taking. You know, pills to keep them
hard, and that raises blood pressure and, you know,
can you do this every day, 5 days a
week as a male performer. So, uh, finding good
male performers, um, that's becoming a little bit of
a challenge as well.
Yeah, OK, so I mean I've guessed that we've
already explored some of that, but would you like
to just leave a final message to people who
have a negative view of sex work and sex
workers? I mean, what would you like to tell
them to perhaps try to make them more open
to Developing a different view of that.
Yeah, it's, that's a tricky one because I know
people that have that stance, and it's really hard
to break through once people have a belief system
in place. It's really hard to, um, you know,
to sway that. But, you know, aside from me
trying to convince, I would just simply say that,
um, you know, we're all sexual animals. We all
enjoy. SEX, masturbation, intimacy, whatever that looks like for
you, and you really ask yourself, do I use
porn for my own private pleasure? And if you
do, and you're still saying porn is bad, you
know, you need to look in the mirror. You're,
you're being a hypocrite. Um, THIS is for entertainment
purposes only. We are producers, actors, directors. We're mothers,
we're sisters, we're, um, you know, we're just people
in the world making, making a living and giving
you something for entertainment that can bring pleasure as
well. Um, SO humanizing this as an industry, normalizing
it as an industry is really important, and that's
what we all really need to work on and
focus on is trying to bring it home. That,
you know, this is, this is normal. It's OK.
If you don't like it, you know you don't
have to watch it, but you don't need to,
uh, demonize everyone who's doing this if you don't
like it. Um, IT'S just, you know, unfortunately, it's
like religion. You know, we've got one religion here
and another religion here, and they've been killing each
other, killing each other in wars, uh, for thousands
of years, just because I don't like. Your God
and you don't like my God, you know, this
is porn. I don't like porn, so let's end
it. But I do like porn. So, why should
we end it if you don't like it, you
know, so it's, I don't know. I don't know.
All I know is I'm glad you're using this
language like humanizing sex work and uh let's normalize
this because, again, just about everybody does some sort
of sexual something. So, you know, let's just stop
denying that and just be real, be human, and
it's not in your face. Uh, IT'S something that
you have to click buttons to get to. So,
you know, we're not trying to walk naked down
your neighborhood street. Um, WE just wanna be able
to, to be able to work in a safe
environment and create the best product that we can
for people, people's entertainment and people's pleasure.
OK, great. So where can people find you? Give
us all your handles, websites, all of that.
Yep, I would just go right to the website
because everything is there. So it's Rachel sh Steele.
S T E E L E.com. That's Rachel-Steel.com. And
there you'll find all of my 5,000+ movies from
two decades and still going strong, and my, all
of my social media and my store where you
can buy lingerie and all kinds of fun things,
and, uh, live chats, live streams, all kinds of
custom videos, whatever you want.
Great. So Rachel, thank you so much for taking
the time to come on the show. It's been
really fun and fascinating to talk with you, and
I really hope that I'm contributing to help humanizing
sex workers through this series, but it's been a
great honor to everyone.
Thank you so much, Ricardo. Yes, and, and you're
doing a wonderful job, and uh I appreciate you,
and I know that our entire community appreciates you
as well.
Hi guys, thank you for watching this interview until
the end. If you liked it, please share it,
leave a like and hit the subscription button. The
show is brought to you by Enlights Learning and
Development done differently. Check their website at enlights.com and
also please consider supporting the show on Patreon or
PayPal. I would also like to give a huge
thank you to my main patrons and PayPal supporters,
Perergo Larsson, Jerry Muller, Frederick Sundo, Bernard Seyaz Olaf,
Alex, Adam Cassel, Matthew Whittingberrd, Arnaud Wolff, Tim Hollis,
Eric Elena, John Connors, Philip Forst Connolly. Then Dmitri
Robert Windegerru Inai Zu Mark Nevs, Colin Holbrookfield, Governor,
Michel Stormir, Samuel Andrea, Francis Forti Agnun, Svergoo, and
Hal Herzognun, Machael Jonathan Labran, John Yardston, and Samuel
Curric Hines, Mark Smith, John Ware, Tom Hammel, Sardusran,
David Sloan Wilson, Yasilla Dezaraujo Romain Roach, Diego Londono
Correa. Yannik Punteran Ruzmani, Charlotte Blis Nicole Barbaro, Adam
Hunt, Pavlostazevski, Alekbaka Madison, Gary G. Alman, Semov, Zal
Adrian Yei Poltontin, John Barboza, Julian Price, Edward Hall,
Edin Bronner, Douglas Fry, Franco Bartolati, Gabriel Pancortez or
Suliliski, Scott Zachary Fish, Tim Duffy, Sony Smith, and
Wisman. Daniel Friedman, William Buckner, Paul Georg Jarno, Luke
Lovai, Georgios Theophannus, Chris Williamson, Peter Wolozin, David Williams,
Dio Costa, Anton Ericsson, Charles Murray, Alex Shaw, Marie
Martinez, Coralli Chevalier, Bangalore atheists, Larry D. Lee Junior.
Old Eringbon. Esterri, Michael Bailey, then Spurber, Robert Grassy,
Zigoren, Jeff McMahon, Jake Zul, Barnabas Raddix, Mark Kempel,
Thomas Dovner, Luke Neeson, Chris Story, Kimberly Johnson, Benjamin
Galbert, Jessica Nowicki, Linda Brendan, Nicholas Carlson, Ismael Bensleyman.
George Ekoriati, Valentine Steinmann, Per Crawley, Kate Van Goler,
Alexander Obert, Liam Dunaway, BR, Massoud Ali Mohammadi, Perpendicular,
Jannes Hetner, Ursula Guinov, Gregory Hastings, David Pinsov, Sean
Nelson, Mike Levin, and Jos Necht. A special thanks
to my producers Iar Webb, Jim Frank Lucas Stink,
Tom Vanneden, Bernardine Curtis Dixon, Benedict Mueller, Thomas Trumbull,
Catherine and Patrick Tobin, John Carlo Montenegro, Al Nick
Cortiz, and Nick Golden, and to my executive producers,
Matthew Lavender, Sergio Quadrian, Bogdan Kanis, and Rosie. Thank
you for all.